como se podrá escuchar es un ambiente
muy festivo el que se vive aquí en
camerún la gente lleva mucho tiempo
esperando la realización de esta copa
africana de naciones que debían recibir
el país anfitrión en 2019 pero que por
problemas en las obras de
infraestructura se terminó se le terminó
adjudicando esta copa en 2021 que luego
fue postergada nuevamente por la
pandemia para inicios de 2022 aquí el
público se va acercando lentamente de a
poco porque en un ratito nada más se va
a estar comenzando la ceremonia
inaugural del torneo que va a repasar
distintos aspectos de la cultura y la
vida aquí en el país del centro de
áfrica y después será el momento de que
comienza a rodar la pelota con el choque
entre los locales de camerún y burkina
faso el equipo camerunés parte como uno
de los favoritos principalmente
sostenidos en su localía y también en su
historia lleva cinco copas africanas de
naciones es el segundo equipo más
ganador de la historia detrás es de
egipto y busca una sexta con un equipo
sostenido también con varias figuras del
fútbol europeo enfrente tendrá un
difícil rival
equipo de burkina faso que viene en
crecimiento la jornada se va a completar
de este grupo a más tarde con el choque
en este mismo estadio entre etiopía y
cabo verde a priori los dos equipos son
más débiles de este grupo a son varias
medidas las que han tomado tanto las
autoridades sanitarias como en la
confederación africana de fútbol la
principal es que todos los espectadores
se tienen que estar vacunados una medida
que ha servido para impulsar la campaña
en el país en un país que tenía
solamente un porcentaje de vacunados del
6 por ciento también los espectadores
tienen que contar con una prueba pcr
negativa realizada en las 72 horas
previas a una prueba de antígenos
realizada en las 24 horas previas y
además la medida adicional que se
anunció en los últimos días es la
reducción de la capacidad en los
estadios para los partidos de camerún en
los estadios estarán a un 80 por ciento
de su capacidad y para el resto de las
elecciones a un 60 por ciento